here
okay
hello
3 45
appreciate it
questions
look here on one channel channel one
there
and i gotta touch it but that's one two
three four five six
it's going straight from here to channel
one oh okay
got it all right channel one on the full
touch
thank you
this thing doesn't matter
that why would that be uh
did you have the same issue
i mean i added all these and then
and then there's the other
but it comes up like about 43 dollars
all right yeah the whole grain truck
right
[Music]
mark it down
okay
i haven't heard but i would have thought
there must be something because it's
already 25 after
oh
wait
[Music]
um
they're here
hello
what's your topic your first um
another another way in which you have
that's exactly
[Laughter]
stay right where you are right now
um
oh yeah
open
my hair
very good
uh
is
no that didn't work
hmm
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
you want to sit back here
so
okay
oh
just yeah
myself
uh
okay
um
so
okay
i need a boy
the press briefing two-minute warning
thank you
thanks brother
oh
oh
so
hi everyone hi
good afternoon
just have a couple of items for you all
at the top i was a little worried about
getting that mask off with the earrings
okay successful good start
um today president biden joined
the house democratic caucus meeting by
phone
to discuss the american rescue plan the
president made clear that the american
rescue plan was designed to meet the
stakes of the public health
and economic crisis and the president
caucus agreed that a final package
must address the crises facing working
families
including housing and food insecurity
and reopening
schools president biden said the cost of
an action and doing too little
is greater than the cost of doing too
much the president also had the
opportunity to meet in the oval office
just a few minutes ago
with leader schumer and the democratic
chairs of the senate committees with
jurisdiction
over the american rescue plan as part of
his ongoing engagement with lawmakers
with
from both sides of the aisle during the
meeting they had a productive
conversation on the status of
legislative proceedings on the package
they were in agreement over the need to
move swiftly to ensure that we get 1400
direct payments to middle and working
class americans
as quickly as possible that we need to
take steps to get immediate relief to
the americans who are struggling with
food insecurity
or facing eviction and that we need to
provide more resources to get shots into
arms
faster the president and the senators
were also in agreement over the need to
go big
and to meet the challenges we face with
a response that will get the job
done in beating this virus and in
protecting our economy from
long-term damage during the conversation
the president and democratic leaders
also agreed to continue working to find
areas of bipartisan agreement
in an effort to integrate ideas and make
the process as bipartisan
as possible there have been lots of
questions from some of you and others
about the differences between
uh the president's plan the democratic
plan and
the plan that has been proposed by um
10 republican senators so i wanted to
outline some of those specifics here for
you
the president's plan would fulfill his
pledge to finish getting two thousand
dollar checks to hard hit americans
and ensure that for example a
kindergarten teacher
making sixty thousand dollars a year
isn't left without additional support
their plan wouldn't provide that teacher
with direct relief
the president's plan would give
americans who are out of work through no
fault of their own
a 400 weekly supplement and uh
and the certainty that it would last
through the worst of the pandemic their
plan
would give unemployed americans less
money and therefore less certainty
the president's plan would keep hundreds
of thousands of teachers
cops firefighters paramedics and other
public servants on the job
their plan offers no money to state and
local governments to keep people on the
front lines of this fight employed
the president's plan would also assist
the millions of families who are faced
who are behind on their rent
and facing potential potential eviction
their plan wouldn't offer any support to
these families
the president's plan would provide
targeted immediate relief
to families with children and essential
workers through an emergency expansion
of the child tax credit and the eitc
their plan would deny relief to 15
million lower income essential
workers the president's plan together
would reduce the number of kids living
in poverty by 5 million this year
and cut child poverty in half their plan
would likely leave millions of
additional
kids out just as importantly the
president's plan would make sure we have
every resource we need
to defeat this virus and get life back
to normal including 130 billion dollars
to help ensure our kids can go back to
school safely
20 billion dollars to mount a nationwide
vaccination campaign
50 billion for more better testing and
critical funding
to improve our ability to track and
defeat emerging coveted 19
strains i know that was a lot but it's a
lot of interest in this issue go ahead
josh
thanks so much jen two questions um
president biden told house democrats
today
that he considered the 1400 direct
payment a promise that he can't break
at the same time a new analysis from the
penn wharton
budget model suggests that 73
of those payments would go into savings
instead of be spent in ways that could
boost growth
i'm wondering what's more important to
keep the promise
or to ensure that the package does all
it can to maximize growth
well first on the penn warren analysis
we've seen that analysis
and i've talked to our economic team
about it and frankly feel it's way out
of step with the majority of studies
on this plan including independent
analysis from
the wall street firm moody's jpmorgan
chase and the brookings institution
and the analysis concludes that our
economy is near capacity
which would be news to the millions of
americans who are out of work or facing
reduced hours and reduced
paychecks so this starting place means
their model is way off
so our view is we're going to listen to
governors we're going to listen to a
broad range of economists we're going to
listen to
health experts uh on what is needed what
the american people need at this point
in time and when
one in seven american families don't
have enough food to eat it's clear that
there is
a great deal of need for assistance
secondly
the president is set to speak to the
state department tomorrow
how does he expect to change the tone
with regard to refugees
china and russia relative to his
predecessor
well um first i would say the
president's visit tomorrow
which we rescheduled because of snow is
largely focused on
his desire to thank the men and women
who are
us who are foreign service officers
civil servants
who are the heart and soul of that
institution and frankly our government
and
i worked there for two and a half years
it's an incredible place and uh they've
had uh
many of them have had a challenging
couple of years uh but
he will also of course uh talk broadly
about foreign policy how could he not if
he is there
this will not be a lay down of his
vision for
every issue and every foreign policy
issue he will have plenty of time to do
that so
uh i just want to kind of expectation
set on what to expect for tomorrow
but you were also asking about the
difference between his approach on
russia and china
you know i think on russia uh you know
his call to president putin
is a a couple of weeks ago two weeks ago
is clear evidence of
exactly that when he called president
putin
he did not hold back he made clear that
while there are areas where we
can work together say new start which is
in the interest of the security of the
united states
he has concerns about a number of areas
of
their reported interference whether it's
in elections uh
in the hacking of the united states uh
the solar winds hacking i should say
reports of bounties on american troops
there's an ongoing review that's uh
that's happening which he also stated in
that
in that conversation so his con
his engagement even directly with
president putin tells you a bit about
the difference alone
uh and on china uh you know the
president's view and
the administration's view is that uh we
need to work with our allies
we need to work with our partners to
align on how we're going to approach our
relationship with china and we need to
approach that relationship from a
position of strength uh
there are obviously key components of
that relationship they're economic
they're strategic
and uh but we're gonna work closely with
our allies he's having those engagements
now we've done a lot of call readouts of
course and also with uh partners on the
hill democrats and republicans on the
best path forward
go ahead thanks jen um the republican
plan matches you guys up on the national
vaccine
top line and also the testing top line
but you tipped through some pretty
significant differences between the
proposal and i know we asked this
seemingly daily at this point but where
is it
where is the space for bipartisan
agreement
when the differences aren't that
significant across major components of
what president wants
well um you know an area where there's
agreement to work together on
is funding for small business um and
that's something of course democrats and
republicans want to do
our view is that this bill itself is
bipartisan 74 percent of the public
support it republicans and democrats
independents across the country
and there is agreement uh that it's
important to work with many republicans
and democrats who fall on different
uh different parts of the political
spectrum
to put their ideas forward and consider
them and that's part of the conversation
and part of the process now happening on
the hill
we will see uh we will see uh what
proposals that
improve the bill that make it better and
there's certainly an openness to that
um several republican senators
said publicly that they believe the
president is in a different place than
his staff
on this issue in particular and he's
more willing to deal perhaps than his
staff is there daylight between the
president and his staff
on the 1.9 trillion absolutely not
i've seen some of those reports uh some
many of them are ludicrous
i've sat in a lot of meetings with the
president of the united states in the
last few weeks and even before then
uh there is no one uh who's going to uh
tell him what to do or hold him back
from his commitment to delivering relief
to the american people and
i would point you to the fact that he
talked about the importance of going big
on a package
back to the campaign uh he talked about
the importance of meeting this moment
back to the campaign so that is
certainly his commitment and that's
exactly what he's working to deliver on
and just one quick one
unback scenes concerning that something
you guys talked about last week i
believe defense production act
um i know you've said all the options
around the table you guys are working
through
um and that it has been launched in at
least a couple of
areas on vaccine supply
is the defense production act being
utilized on that front and if not is
there a timeline is that something that
remains on the table right now
um to poster i think one of the issues
have you guys identified as the biggest
problem
uh absolutely it's on the table and uh
you know the reason the president
invoked the defense production act was
because he wanted to have
a range of options uh for any moment
where there was a reduction in supply
on um on on
you know materials on ppe on
syringes and at the appropriate time we
can certainly
use it for that but right now our focus
is on working with
pfizer and moderna we have confidence in
their ability to
produce the number of vaccines that the
government has ordered
on the timeline that we have committed
to and so
and that means that we would have enough
vaccines here to be able to
vaccinate every american by the summer
so our focus is
is really more on evaluating our team
evaluating where there are needs for
supplies and materials that would help
deliver the vaccines into the arms of
americans
you saw the president say earlier he's
still confident he can get some
republican support
mitt romney was asked about that a
little while ago and he said well if
they're not going to budge out the 1.9
trillion dollar number
it's not going to happen he was then
asked well is there can you give us a
specific example
of something that uh demonstrates the
differences you didn't mention it he
says
the 360 billion or so for states and
localities
is that something that is considered
negotiable by the white house
well i'd be interested because i didn't
see so i guess i'm asking you a question
uh
what senator romney said about whether
they would propose any funding for state
and local
he said the most recent reports show
that the average state in america only
lost about 10 to 1 percent of the
revenue so
it should perhaps be adjusted well they
are not proposing any
so i would suggest given that they also
supported
160 or 180 billion in a package that
moved forward under the trump
administration that that's a place where
we would certainly certainly welcome an
offer from their end on
what state and local funding they'd
support one other on
economic relief related to the pandemic
there's a there was a full page ad in
the new york times last week
put there by several prominent women
calling on the bite administration
implement what they call a marshall plan
for mobs
in the first 100 days has the president
seen the ad and would he support the
idea of monthly payments to mothers
who are saddled by this payment well uh
as a mom myself i can confirm for you
that the conversation i have most
frequently with friends on zoom calls
is about the impact of the pandemic on
working moms across the country
and what the president has certainly um
concerned about as we all are is the
fact that this has an uh
and a disproportionate impact on
communities of color
on women of color who are working many
of them working on
jobs as front line workers and vital
playing vital roles and industries
across the country
and it's certainly an issue that uh
secretary yellen his economic team are
focused on and will
be looking for ways to help appease
the president said yesterday he had a
chance to contact the families of the
fbi agents
killed in south florida has he been able
to do that yet
we will follow up with you after the
briefing i did not have a chance to ask
about that before i came out here today
and then earlier today canada designated
the proud boys as a terrorist
organization putting them alongside al
qaeda
isis and al-shabaab does the u.s plan to
do the same
i had seen that ed before we came out
here and asked
certainly our team to make sure we had a
little bit of guidance on that for all
of you
we of course have a review underway a
domestic violent extremist extremism i
should say a review that's underway by
our national security team
to take a look at violence and this type
of concerning
group activity across the country i
expect we will wait to for that review
to conclude before we make any
determinations
it's an ongoing review and when it's
concluded i'm sure we'll have more to
say about
our view go ahead thank you jen uh the
top republican
on the house armed services committee is
asking you to apologize
for some of the comments that you made
yesterday in the briefing room about the
space force
will you apologize i did uh send a tweet
last night you may not all be on twitter
maybe they're not on twitter that said
we
invite the members of space force here
to provide an update to all of you
on all of the important work they're
doing and we certainly look forward to
conceiving continued updates from there
uh from their team big picture here i
mean does
the space force have the full support
of the bind administration or is the
president at some point perhaps going to
try to get rid of it
or in some way diminish it they
absolutely have the full support of the
biden administration
and we are not revisiting the decision
to establish the space force
the desire for the department of defense
to focus greater attention and resources
on the growing security challenges in
space
has long been a bipartisan issue
informed by numerous independent
commissions and studies conducted across
multiple administrations and thousands
of men and women proudly serve in the
space force
as you know it was established by
congress and any other steps would
actually have to be taken by congress
not by the administration
one more space question nasa's artemis
program which was the trump era program
to return american astronauts to the
moon by 2024
what is the president's plan what is he
going to do with that program is he
going to keep it intact
i am personally interested in space i
think it's a fascinating area of study
uh but i have not spoken with our team
about this particular program so let me
see if we can get you a more
uh informed uh overview of that one more
question if i said sorry about the
president's comments last night as he
was paying his respects to the
fbi agents that lost their lives or were
injured
he said by and large the vast majority
of these men and women are decent
honorable people what did he mean by
that the vast majority part
that's exactly what he meant go ahead
kristen thank you
jen um president biden has been very
clear that one of
his core promises to the american people
is to try to unify
this country how can he take steps to
unify the country while the impeachment
trial is going on
well he can focus his efforts which is
exactly what he's doing
on delivering necessary relief to the
american public
and using his forum to talk about how
he's going to reopen schools
how he's going to get shots in the arms
of americans how he's going to ensure
that
the one in seven american families who
are concerned they can't put food on the
table can do exactly that
that's how he's spending his time as as
we started this briefing and how he will
continue to spend it moving forward
what's his message to republicans who
say that the very trial itself
undercuts any efforts that you need he
he invites uh republicans to work with
him on bringing relief to the american
public and that's why he invited them
here
many of them here on monday and why he
will continue to engage with the moving
forward
talk about his agenda
executive order speaking to the american
people almost on a
daily basis obviously the focus is going
to shift to the senate next week
how concerned is he that the senate
trial will undercut his momentum
i think the president has been clear
there's an urgency to delivering
relief to the american people and uh
it's important and vital
that the house and senate uh work
quickly uh to get this bill packet
passed
up within the week when you say i'm not
giving a deadline i'm just conveying
what he has stated many times publicly
and we are confident they have the
ability to uh walk into gum at the same
time
one more question there's discussion on
the hill about stripping
congresswoman marjorie taylor green of
her committee
assignments does president biden believe
that she should be stripped of those
assignments
we've resisted speaking of her in this
briefing room and i'm not going to do
that today
because it's up to the hell to make that
determination go ahead um
thank you jen and then with reuters um
president biden has always expressed
support for unions and in fact
has distributed a plan to kind of
strengthen more for organizing around
the country
um there are thousands of workers
at an amazon facility in alabama uh that
are currently gearing up
uh to cast a vote and potentially form a
union inside the company this will be
the first of its kind inside amazon
does the white house and president biden
support their efforts to organize
and foreign as you've noted the
president is a strong
long-time believer and supporter of the
efforts of labor unions and workers i
have not spoken with
him or economic team about this
particular report nor had i seen it
before i came out here if there's
anything more to provide you we're
happy to follow up with you directly and
i did have another
question on on secretary yellen calling
for a meeting
with a top financial regulators on
gamestop um and uh we understand the
meeting is likely to happen this week
uh will the meeting be uh held on
thursday
and will the focus uh really be on
whether
robin hood uh treated retail investors
unfairly over
large institutional investors well i
would send you to the treasury
department um for any specifics on the
timing of the meeting or the focus of
the meeting for any of you who have not
seen this report
secretary yellen has called a meeting
with the sec frb frbny
and cftc she believes the integrity of
markets is important and has asked for a
discussion of recent volatility
in financial markets and whether recent
activities are consistent
with investor protection and fair and
efficient markets that'll be the focus
of the meeting but for more details i
would certainly send you to the treasury
team
good job any update on the release of
the white house visitor logs either
were you able to figure out if you can
technically access the trump
administration
visitor logs i was um we cannot um that
is under the purview of the national
archives
um so i'd certainly point you to there
uh and
in terms of the uh our plans to release
the visitor logs we do plan to do that
on a quarterly basis just as the
obama biden administration did as well
and then one other thing also on unions
mitch mcconnell was critical today of
giving generous
funding to school districts where their
the unions are not allowing the schools
to
open do you have any reaction to that i
would say that the
the purpose of giving funding or
supporting funding and getting it to
school districts is to ensure that
teachers are safe that kids are safe
that there is necessary ppe that there's
ventilation in the school that
uh that there is um the uh the
the environment that allows for uh
children to return safely
and that is the president's focus that's
why he also wants to reopen schools
and wants them not just to reopen but
wants them to stay open which as a mom
that is pivotal um
and uh that's that's but he he knows
it's essential that it's done in a safe
way
unions not allowing some school
districts to reopen there's discussions
in different districts as you well know
um between uh school districts or um
and uh and elected officials and uh
and the unions and we certainly uh hope
and encourage
progress on that front but the
president's focus is on the schools
reopening safely and them staying open
go ahead summon um a couple questions
thanks john um
so during the georgia runoff um
president biden campaigned specifically
on two thousand dollar stimulus checks
and obviously
as we've discussed uh the payment is
fourteen hundred dollars there doesn't
seem to be
an active discussion and actually
raising that amount so is that a broken
promise to voters
who may have been expecting two thousand
dollar checks um if democrats won
and would the administration be open to
raising that amount
well you're right that the the president
is very focused
on ensuring millions of americans
receive those checks and that pivotal
relief at this point in time
there was 600 payments as you know in
the 900 billion dollar package that
passed in december
this is 1400 together that's 2 000 so it
would be delivering on the promise he
made and it's something that he is
firmly sticking by another question on
immigration um
the bible administration has extended um
temporary protected status for uh
syrian nationals obviously the trump
administration cut off tps protections
for many other countries such as el
salvador nicaragua and haiti
so does the administration plan to
reinstate those tps protections for
those countries
it is all under review at this point in
time and obviously the president has
talked about his own commitment to
reinstating tps
in certain cases but um it has not the
review has not been completed at this
point in time
um but thanks john um earlier today on
the call with house democrats the
president talked about
better targeting the stimulus checks i'm
wondering if you could just explain
what he meant by that and what might be
under consideration sure
well as we've said in here a few times
but um but i know this is an ongoing
process you know
the president having served in the
senate for 36 years fully recognizes
that
uh the bill he proposed that he did a a
um prime time address on two weeks ago
uh that may not look exactly like the
bill that comes out and he knows that
that's part of the legislative process
so
further targeting means uh not the size
of the check
it means the the the income level
of people who received the check and
that's something that
uh has been under discussion has been a
conclusion but certainly is open to
having that discussion
and i also want to ask uh in the
previous administration
often when coron virus cases came up in
the white house people have been
positive
it came out in the news media i was
wondering if uh if um
this white house has a policy on
releasing information about people who
test positive
in the white house her and in the
administration who have contact with
white house officials
sure well um if for anybody who covered
the campaign and i was not on the
campaign but what they tried to do was
uh be very transparent about anyone who
had any contact with
would have been in close proximity to
the president or vice president
and release if they had a coveted
positive test
and so we will certainly model that
transparency um
if and if and when that occurs here and
a
venture to provide accurate and
up-to-date information as quickly as
possible
to all of you not through the media but
but directly um i mean you are the media
but you know what i mean go ahead
hi thanks jen um i have one question and
then one for my colleagues who can't be
here
sure um the cdc director is saying that
the vaccination of teachers is not a
prerequisite for safe reopening of
schools
does the white house agree with this and
should states be prioritizing teachers
over other essential workers in the
vaccine line
well i saw the comments of um dr
wolenski but i will say that even she
would say if she were standing here
she's welcome to come anytime but she's
in atlanta uh
that they have not released their
official guidance yet from the cdc on
the vaccination of teachers and what
would be needed to
ensure the safe reopening of schools and
so we'd certainly
defer to that which we hope to see soon
the president himself has talked about
the importance and the priority of
vaccinating teachers and in most states
they're in the 1b category
of vaccination um and but it is up to
states to determine prioritization
obviously there's federal guidelines but
and we work closely with governors but
we leave it to them but certainly
ensuring teachers are vaccinated
prioritizing teachers
uh is is important to the president
and this is from a colleague oh sorry go
ahead yeah following the 2020 election
28 states have brought forward 106
different bills
related to voting access according to
the brennan center for justice
is president biden keeping track of
those efforts and will he talk with
states to ensure
americans aren't restricted from voting
in future elections
well the president's priority is
certainly ensuring and the vice
president's priority is certainly
ensuring more people
not fewer people have access to voting
and that it is easier not harder to do
that
we saw some examples of voting by mail
or
early early voting given kovid that
could be models for the future
uh it's certainly an issue he's
following and his team keeps him abreast
on
i don't think there's been an update in
since he was inaugurated um
to him but it's certainly an issue he
cares personally about as does the vice
president
go ahead and back yeah good afternoon
owen jensen with ewtn
global catholic network uh president
biden has
stated he wants to unite the country in
the first two weeks he's been in office
however
and much of the great appointment of
pro-life americans he has
revoked the mexico city policy
he has ordered a review of title 10 and
issued a statement
strongly supporting roe v wade is the
president
going to make any effort to reach out to
pro-life americans in his administration
well those have long been the
president's positions and uh he
certainly
uh was just restating them and
delivering on promises he made on the
campaign trail but
the president will will reach out to all
americans
um and that is uh how he's going to
govern what he talked about in his
inaugural address
uh and he has every intention of
delivering on that promise
you described him as a developed
catholic will he use his faith to guide
him in any policy decision making
he does attend church nearly every
weekend and that's something that's
important to him personally and to his
family
and he's talked about the impact of his
faith on healing
and everything he's been through as a
human being so certainly it's a guide to
him as a human being
go ahead thanks um earlier you
mentioned a number of topics that
president biden and putin had discussed
one that you didn't mention is the two
marines who are
imprisoned uh trevor reed and paul
whalen
uh trevor from uh from texas uh
had an appeal today in moscow the u.s
ambassador called his conviction
a mockery of justice what is the us
doing
to secure their release and do you
consider
these two marines to be hostages well
uh ambassador sullivan who i think you
were referring to
today called trevor reed's trial on
mockery of justice and
we certainly agree and as you know we
have a range of
means of communications with the
russians at several levels
we have a secretary of state who's now
confirmed we have a national security
advisor and we have a number of
officials
in the state department but i'll use
this as an opportunity to once again
call
on russia to swiftly release both mr
reed and paul
whalen on doing so on the heels of
extending new start would demonstrate
that russia is ready to move
past intractable issues within the
bipartisan
the bilateral excuse me lots of
bipartisan talk in here today
bilateral relationship um but that's our
view and we certainly raised this at
every opportunity or
any other consequences under
consideration
well uh there's also a review we've
announced here of course and i talked
about a little bit at the beginning of
uh our relationship and certainly a
number of um
issues that are being looked into by the
national security team uh
and once that review is concluded we'll
have more to say on our policies moving
forward
do you does the administration consider
them to be hostages i don't think i'm
gonna add a new category or cat
organization from here today
go ahead jen i want to follow up on
ventilation in the schools in terms of
reopening them safely
how exactly does the white house see
that playing out is the president
saying that no school should be reopened
unless they get a brand new or renovated
ventilation system
i think the president is saying that and
the cdc i should say more importantly
and our health and medical experts are
saying that
ventilation and proper ventilation in
schools and
especially schools public schools that
have uh don't have often the benefit of
tuition and things along those lines
need to have proper ventilation we've
seen from health and medical experts
that that is
something that contributes to ensuring
the safety of people and
indoors which is part of what school is
so they're just
conveying that that's an important uh
component of looking at school safety
and and how we can reopen schools so
it's not a prerequisite
there haven't been prerequisites set
there have been there have been
uh you know broad objectives that have
been set by the cdc and others they have
also not put out their specific
detailed guidelines yet and we'll look
uh look forward to seeing those and
and abiding by them and communicating
about them from here go ahead josh
the president has said he really wants
to protect the middle class
and i'm wondering when it comes to
things like direct payments what's the
income
range by which you define the middle
class
like how much does someone who's middle
class
how much do they earn what what's the
range well
there are ranges in the bill as you know
um that are what the president proposed
and what he outlined during his
primetime address
um i don't know that he looked at the
bill as his own personal
definition of the middle class as much
as a definition of the people who need
help the most uh so that bill is the
rough range and how you're thinking
about it
i don't i think i just said it's not the
definition he he wasn't looking to
answer the question for economists
around the world on how to define the
middle class he was defining
who needs help the most now and that's
how the bill is defined and why he's
so um focused on ensuring those checks
got out to the american people
thank you for calling the voting
question um
voting rights act update or john lewis
um you guys have majorities in the house
in the senate we talked about it on the
campaign trail
given shelby holder and the change of
pre-clearance is that a priority and if
it's a priority when
i understand you've only given two weeks
but with the majorities when do you push
forward on that
priority it remains a priority of course
um the president's number one focus
though remains getting the american
rescue plan through
uh he's also going to talk more about a
built back better plan
as we get into the early spring or late
winter i guess
uh and that will be another priority as
an immigration package that he has
proposed
to the hill as well so ensuring that it
is easier
to vote that more people have access to
voting
uh that we are making it um you know a
part of uh
the right of being an american as a is a
priority to the president but
i don't have a timeline or a date for
you on when we would push for that bill
to move forward one other quick one on
burma new mcconnell after he spoke with
the president yesterday said he expects
quickly
expects the administration to quickly
sanction the military leaders
um i mean we talked about the changes in
foreign aid
what is the timeline on sanctions is
leader mcconnell right that
sanctions will be coming quickly well
one i will note that the state
department very rapidly completed
their review um designating or naming
the military coup in burma in a very
short period of time which i think is
something
this is bipartisanship in action that
senator mcconnell agreed on
um and obviously um the detention
continued detention of unsansu-chi other
civilian officials
and the declaration of national state of
emergency are a direct assault on
burma's transition
to democracy and the rule of law we're
continuing to
uh review sanction our sanctions
authorities and other options
uh it is certainly a priority to this
administration i can tell you jake
sullivan called me on sunday night to
tell me we had to put a statement out
because it was so important we had our
votes avoid
voice out there and the pro we obviously
put out a statement from the president
acted quickly i don't have an exact
timeline for you but it is a it is a
priority and certain
certainly reviewing our sanctions
authorities and seeing where there's
action
to take there is something the team is
focused on go ahead
um have you guys been talking at all
about the iowa caucuses or the lineup
for the the next too soon jennifer too
soon about nevada
wanting to go first i don't
we we are certainly not focused on uh on
the next political campaign here quite
yet um
and we don't have any any point of view
to share on the order of the
presidential nominating contests uh
though nevada's a little warmer but you
know
uh all great states um go ahead jen you
said that you will be checking with the
nsc and the president about the summer
olympics i believe
can you tell us does he think at this
point that it is safe for the u.s team
to go
to tokyo uh well i know there's been
um some reporting on this um we're not
currently
talking about um changing our posture or
our plans as it relates to the beijing
olympics
we consult of course closely with allies
and partners at all levels
to define our common concerns and
establish a shared approach but
this is there's no discussion underway
of a change in our plans
from the united states at this point in
time
go ahead thanks one of the law
enforcement gaps
that was identified after the riot
january 6
was that president trump had insisted on
this focus on
antifa and i'm wondering what president
biden has done to redirect
an emphasis on right-wing extremism well
we've launched an entire review
on domestic violent extremism uh that
would cover
uh that across the board um activity
across the board concerning activity
across the board it's not a political
review it's a review of
domestic violent extremism and uh our
plan is to look at that have our team
look at that
again not through a political lens but
through the lens of uh
national security experts and teams who
have expertise in this area
and uh when that review is concluded we
will have more to say on it
can i just follow up very quickly on the
olympics you said beijing
i'm happy about tokyo oh sorry um
there's a lot of olympics questions
going on i
don't think that it is safe for us
athletes again nothing has changed about
our plans um
and i would send you to the usoc to
discuss anything further on plans for
athletes
kristin go ahead thank you for that
clarification too lots of olympics
um can i follow up uh with a previous
question and just circle back to
president biden's comments yesterday
in the oval office when he said the vast
vast majority of u.s law enforcement
officers were decent honorable people
why did he want
to why did he think it was important to
stress that the vast majority
because i think he believes that the men
and women who have been serving
our country in a variety of capacities
uh have uh you know been criticized
been um some have been threatened uh
they're the roles they're playing have
been
uh questioned over the last several
years and
he wanted to reiterate his support for
uh
the important work they do it's also why
he's visiting the state department
tomorrow
not to say that all of them are i mean
he made that delineation
i think the point he's making is that
despite reports of
you know individuals in in different
areas
who may have done things that are
problematic that the vast majority of
men and women serving are in our law
enforcement
roles serving uh in a civil service role
serving in roles across government
do vital and essential work for the
american people
go ahead thanks sebastian smith i know i
remember your mask it stands out has
flamingos on it in case anyone's
wondering the flamingo guy
it's too late sorry about that i'm gonna
i'm gonna owe you a drink later flamingo
guys okay
um on again on sanctions this time in
russia is there any discussion of
targeting people close to putin over
what's happening with navalny and the
opposition there
and has the president uh talked to eu
allies about this the president has
certainly
spoken with a number of european allies
about a range of issues of mutual
interest of course including russia
in terms of what sanctions options may
exist or what options in terms of a
response may exist
president of course reserves the right
to respond in the manner
and course of his choosing at any point
in time
but we're going to let this review uh
complete uh
and then our policy teams will make
decisions about uh
any uh specific uh steps they'll take in
response
okay a little one related but not
exactly the same uh
does the president have any position on
the um
the activity the presence of of outlets
like russia today and sputnik
um which i believe maybe even come here
sometimes i don't know um
but does he have a position on that
because in some countries they're seen
as out and out
propaganda tools of the kremlin even
things are fairly frosty with putin
right now
what's the position i think it's i have
not spoken with the president about
rt or sputnik i think it's pretty
factual to say they are tools of
propaganda who work on behalf of the
russian government
i don't know that anyone would question
that or raise your hand and happy to
discuss
uh but i've not discussed that with him
specifically i do know that when i was
at the state department
they attended the briefing i had a
little fun with them from time to time
but
uh they attended the briefing they asked
questions but i think there's no
question as we're trying to decipher
information that's accurate and
inaccurate
it's important for the american people
to know that there are outlets working
on behalf of foreign governments who
have an agenda
and they're not playing the role of free
press and pre-free media as you all are
they're working in the white house i
haven't seen them around here um i'm not
sure if they're in the white house
correspondent association
uh you'd have to ask them that question
but i all i'm conveying is it's
important for people to understand and
know
uh that there's an agenda and that they
are not the same as
ap abc other outlets um bbc
around the world uh go ahead can you
clarify
what president biden's goal is for the
number of vaccines
um i i thought he had raised it to 150
but zeitz on today's call said that it
was a hundred million
oh the president is always going to push
his team to go as
as big on vaccine distribution as
possible but our goal remains 100
million
shots in the arms of americans in 100
days and that was a goal that was set
in the fall before a single vaccine had
been put in the arm of an american
and it was uh seen as bold and ambitious
at the time uh but we're not going to
stop at a hundred million uh we're not
declaring victory that's that's that we
wanted to set markers for ourselves
uh so that's uh the marker we set and
we're working to achieve it
go ahead um senators comes in carper
earlier today said that uh cabinet
confirmations came up during their
meeting i was wondering if the
president's been frustrated by the case
on the
senate side and whether he had braced
out with his messages to senators
well the president i always wanted to
move faster that's what i can confirm
having
been here twice um but you know there
certainly was a delay
in the confirmation of a number of our
cabinet nominees
over the course of weeks some of them
were slower paced than they should have
been early on
uh and there are people we would like to
see uh in place obviously ali mjorkas
was fortunately confirmed yesterday to
secretary of homeland security we'd of
course love
for the senate to move forward with the
confirmation of attorney general merrick
garland
future attorney general i guess i should
say merrick garland uh
in order to deliver on the president's
promise of
an independent justice department that's
not influenced by politics that would
certainly be a break in the past
so there are still key positions that
have not moved through the confirmation
process
that we are eager to see move forward we
have seen though some progress in the
last week or so
and a number of who have moved forward
um former
uh mayor p buddha judge of course
yesterday uh just confirmed as the
first lgbtq secretary in a cabinet
um he's going to play a pivotal role on
our economic planning uh but
there's more to be done it's something
that the president and his team will
continue to push on uh to get his full
team in place
go ahead do you know on the cloud
contract for the pentagon awarded to
microsoft
do you know if the biden white house is
going to review that at all because i
mean you know that
during the trump administration it was
awarded to microsoft instead of amazon
and president trump had some feelings
about amazon and
i heard that you saw that a review uh i
would certainly send you to the pentagon
on that uh jennifer and i'll i if
there's more
to report from here i will let you know
but i would certainly send you to the
pentagon
go ahead all the way in the back would
president biden be open to having
mandatory year-round schooling to get
kids
caught up so many kids who are falling
behind would be open to something like
that or having
full-time summer school whatever it
takes i have not discussed
full-time or year-round schooling uh
with the president uh of course
as you know that requires often state
funding and that often is up to
governors to know if they can provide
that funding
um but i don't think i have anything
further for you on that
all right did anyone not get a question
okay
thank you everyone
[Laughter]
here